so klipp macht sinn weil hier rundum luz
an der algarve eben zahlreiche klippen
sind und weil offensichtlich deutsche
ermittler vom bka davon ausgehen dass
die eventuell an einer klippe entweder
vergraben wurde oder eben vielleicht
auch mit dem täter kontakt haben sollte
genau es dazu wissen wir noch nicht weil
die ermittler sich da auch noch bedeckt
halten
auf einem hügel also auch eine art
krippe steht auch diese baracke hier im
hintergrund dieser erste wohnsitz von
christian b wo er mitte der 90er jahre
hier nach portugal praktisch geflohen
ist vor dieser haftstrafe die er eben
nicht antreten wollte
und in diesem haus hat er ungefähr zehn
jahre lang gelebt hat das immer wieder
auch vermietet untervermietet war hier
also ab und zu dort war ab und zu auch
wieder weg das ist eine gegend die heißt
legasthenie ist unweit von looz hinter
einem hügel praktisch gehört nicht mehr
zur los ist aber 56 minuten fahrweg
entfernt das heißt er kann eben die
gegend auch von hier aus sehr gut
kennengelernt haben mit diesen elf
jahren in denen er sich aufgehalten hat
die gegend ist schwach besiedelt nur es
gibt viele brachflächen wo man sich eben
auch vorstellen kann wo man eventuell
eben auch leichen verschwinden lassen
könnte ohne jetzt spekulieren zu wollen
aber diese gegend ist also durchaus
unübersichtlich und zersiedelt hier sind
auch baracken gesund alte stelle die
verfallen und die leute kennen sich so
vage die unmittelbaren nachbarn dieses
objektes hier kennen auch den besitzer
den eigentlichen besitzer einen
engländer nur vage wissen ja ist ein
enger der soll auch in england wohnen
das ist alles so ein bisschen unklar
hier also eigentlich ein perfekter ort
um unterzutauchen
und genau das hat christian beer hier
auch versucht johannes das ist gerade
angesprochen
dort ist sehr viel brachland drumherum
wurde denn die gegend untersucht von
ermittlern
also das ist auffällig dass wir hier
jetzt seit zwei tagen vor ort sind und
von der portugiesischen polizei oder
auch von scotland yard oder auch vom bka
bisher niemanden gesehen haben
es sind also keine polizeiketten die
hier die hügel ab kämen mit hunden oder
mit hubschrauber wärmebildkamera etc
es ist einfach nur ist ein kollegen zu
sehen aus england natürlich sehr viele
portugiesen sind hier ein paar deutsche
journalisten sowie wir aber von
ermittlern von polizisten haben wir
bisher überhaupt noch nichts gesehen